et cette entité aujourd'hui c'est vous
maylis vestri bonjour bonjour bienvenue
sur ce plateau vous êtes productrice
entre autres choses de documentaire pour
france culture et vous avez réalisé un
podcast formidable en cinq épisodes qui
a été diffusé au moment du jubilé de la
reine cet été qui s'appelle c'est dans
la série grande traversée elisabeth de
queen qui retrace l'itinéraire de celles
qui n'étaient pas destinées faut-il le
rappeler à être rennes avant de revenir
sur le fond quelques mots de la forme et
de l'objet médiatique et historique dont
il va être question tout à l'heure en
1952 le couronnement d'elizabeth ii
avait été suivi par 2 177 millions de
téléspectateurs dans le monde ce qui
était déjà inouïe là on parle alors
difficile de prédire mais de 1 2 3 4
milliards de personnes c'est presque
plus de la moitié de la population
mondiale oui c'est l'une des
spécificités d'ailleurs d'elisabeth deux
d'être une reine de l'image c'est à dire
qu'elle a accepté effectivement que son
couronnement soient filmés elle a aussi
été beaucoup mis en scène dans les
photographies d'abord de cecil beaton
qui était le grand photographe royal de
l'époque et puis dans la peinture donc
c'est un objet aussi un sujet artistique
elisabeth ii un sujet politique qu'un
sujet géopolitique un sujet de chansons
donc il ya sept cette attention sur elle
et sur cette image il ya même d'ailleurs
des commentateurs royaux qui disent les
commentateurs royaux qui disent que
c'est une sorte de toile blanche la
monarchie sur laquelle on projette que
l'on veut donc avant tout cette image là
de symboles et ce soft power à travers
ses vêtements et là l'image qu'elle
donne de la royauté donc les funérailles
évidemment ne font pas exception c'est
aussi encore un élément de soft power à
la fois pour la monarchie de
communication sur la suite les
successeurs les inquiétudes qui peut y
avoir à l'égard du roi maintenant
charles iii et puis c'est aussi pour
l'état évidemment l'occasion de
représenter ce qui était la monarque
mais aussi la chef d'état de soixante
dix années de règne on va revenir sur
les enjeux et effectivement je sais que
vous êtes une femme de deux radios mais
ce qu'on va vivre aujourd'hui peut-être
le dernier événement notre histoire en
mondiovision ce qui paraît interne
vraiment pour le coup du siècle dernier
oui mais c'est quand même la reine de la
deuxième guerre mondiale qui a traversé
c'est la dernière qui a été témoin de
cette époque là qui a rencontré tous les
grands chefs d'état du commonwealth qui
a connu l'indépendance des pays
justement du commonwealth de l'ancien
empire et qui a suivi qui a accompagné
cette décolonisation l'a donc elle est
un symbole aussi d'une génération malgré
tout du devoir d'une génération
sacrifiée elle a connu les bombardements
de londres elle a était réfugiée avec sa
soeur elle se sont réfugiés au château
de windsor donc d'ailleurs tour revient
à windsor à windsor c'est vraiment le
centre de la famille royale c'est le nom
qu'a décidé de choisir le grand père
d'elizabeth ii georges 5 pour sa
dynastie c'était une cet accès au cobo
gotha pour cacher en quelque sorte ses
racines germaniques de la famille
britannique et a voulu l'ancré dans dans
la famille britannique avec en prenant
ce nom du château de windsor et la honte
elle va rejoindre la chapelle saint
georges elle va rejoindre la crypte des
monarques au château de windsor et son
mari et bien aimé philippe pour rebondir
sur ce que vous disiez emmanuel macron a
eu cette phrase très juste en
s'adressant aux britanniques au moment
du décès de l'annoncé du décès de la
reine il a dit pour vous elle était
votre reine pour nous elle ne l était la
reine c'est effectivement la seule reine
que tout le monde connaît le nombre
d'expressions passé dans le dans le
domaine public je ne suis pas la reine
d'angleterre il n'y en aura plus des
comme ça c'est d'ailleurs peut-être
l'élément le plus important outre sa
personnalité c'est le fait que ce soit
une reine et ça ça avait quelque chose
aussi de très singulier finalement des
rois il y en a eu beaucoup et il y en a
encore beaucoup et la spécificité de la
de la loi justement de l'héritage en
grande bretagne fait qu elle aurait été
évidemment elle n'aurait pas été sur le
trop si elle avait eu un frère même
cadets mais que les femmes peuvent
régner et c'est vrai que le fait qu'ils
aient eu si peu de femmes rennes dans
l'histoire et qu'elle est tenu ce rôle
là à une époque où c'était tout à fait
inédit ça donnait aussi sa particularité
orange 2 en gardant en tête de paradoxe
assez fou de l'histoire d'elizabeth elle
est l'une des reines de l'histoire qui
aura eu le plus long règne alors qu'elle
ne devait pas être reine de naissance en
tout cas et puis on l'a dit elisabeth
était l'une des femmes les plus célèbres
du monde si ce n'est la plus célèbre
alors que dell dell intime on ne sait
quasiment rien il ya un commentateur
anglais qui s'appelle david beck lui qui
parle de elle dit c'est comme un test de
rorschach vous savez ce test avec les
tâches on voit dans la royauté ce que
l'on veut et c'est vrai cette neutralité
qui est une réserve constitutionnel
c'est son devoir de rennes et de
monarque est de rester dans cette
réserve là de ne jamais prendre parti
d'être au dessus de ce jeu politique la
ce a assuré une forme de stabilité mais
aussi c'est une sorte d'image de façade
comme ça et elle a mieux que d'autres
tenues cette réserve constitutionnel
d'ailleurs bien des inquiétudes à
l'égard du roi charles iii viennent du
fait qu'il s'est beaucoup exprimé sur
divers sujets politiques on sait à peu
près où ils se situent et qu'on se
demande bien comment est ce qu'il va
être capable de retenir ses chevaux à
l'avenir et de rester dans cette réserve
qui est très important parce que elle
est le principe même de la monarchie
constitutionnelle un chef d'état sans
pouvoir totalement dépourvues de
pouvoirs qui est là pour représenter
pour être l'ambassadeur de son pays mais
qui n'est pas là pour gouverner c'est là
la contrepartie du droit du sang et cet
équilibre qu'on trouvait justement les
britanniques donc elle était très
attachée à sa elle a toujours fait le
choix d'ailleurs de la fonction par
dessus ses contraintes familiales les
désirs de chacun donc elle est restée
dans ce rôle mieux que d'autres et donc
on est on est justement les inquiétudes
des anglais à l'égard de du prince
charles devenu devenu roi c'est de voir
à quel moment il va être capable de
rentrer dans les chaussures comme on dit
en anglais de sa mère d'être capable de
tenir ce rôle de représentation avec
tout le respect justement de
non-ingérence que cela nécessite
et vous est ce que vous avez appris des
choses pour revenir à la reine en
travaillant sur sur cette grande série
pour france culture 2 de son intimité
enfin de son de son de sa personnalité
que vous ne saviez pas alors oui et non
c'est à dire qu'on a toujours des
informations en creux parce que même par
exemple le fleuriste qu'il a reçues
quand elle est venue inauguré les
marchés aux fleurs à paris disait elle
n'a pas le droit de dire quelle est sa
fleur préférée donc elle parce que tout
de suite ce serait promouvoir sa serai
voilà donc on ne sait rien de personnel
ce que l'on sait c'est son amour de la
campagne des chevaux des animaux c'est
son manque d'ambition au départ le fait
qu'elle était plutôt quelqu'un de
discret qui aurait vécu volontiers dans
l'ombre de son mari qui était à la royal
navy donc on sait que c'est une femme
plutôt discrète qui a souffert parfois
de son manque d'éducation dû à sa
génération d'être une femme justement
qu'on a peu éduqués qui n'avait pas le
droit d'être à l'université dont qui a
dû finalement se débrouiller avec des
atouts personnels qui sont peut-être les
liens qu'elle qu'elle a su former ce que
l'on connaît peut-être de plus personnel
sur elizabeth 2 c'est sa capacité à
émerveiller en quelques secondes tout le
monde vous parle de ça tout les gens
pour rencontrer la reine 10 elle pose un
regard sur vous il ya quelque chose de
magnétique elle s'intéresse à vous
quelques minutes et on se rappelle toute
sa vie donc il ya une sorte d'aura
personnel justement qu'elle n'a été
qu'un hôtel a été capable de jouer pour
créer des liens intenses en quelques
minutes c'est fou que ça fait dix jours
qu'on parle d'une femme qu'on connaît si
peu en réalité leur pour revenir à
l'événement de la journée ses
funérailles pour le coup la seule chose
qu'on ne connaissait pas ou alors qu
elle ne connaissait pas a été peut-être
la liste des invités et encore ce qui va
se passer tout à l'heure et répétés à la
seconde près au millimètre près depuis
quoi 10 ans 20 ans on est probablement
l'opération de london bridge est
extrêmement rodez elle a pu décider
c'est aussi il faut savoir que c'est un
enjeu énorme qui la dépasse largement il
ya ces décisions personnelles
on a pu le voir dans à travers des
discours politiques le fait qu'elle ait
choisi que camilla deviennent reine
consort elle a réglé un problème
constitutionnel important et un problème
lié à l'institution ça aurait pu être
l'objet de débats pendant des semaines
et des semaines au parlement et au sein
du gouvernement s'il n'avait pas tranché
ne l'avait pas dérangé cette question à
la prochaine question alors même qu'elle
était absente
justement au au mariage du prince
charles à l'époque et de la future reine
consort donc le fait qu'elle ait réglé
cette question c'est une donnée très
importante pour ce qui est des
funérailles il faut savoir aussi que
c'est une sorte de boucle 70 ans de
règne il ya une grande crainte justement
de ce qui va se passer plus tard pour
les relations avec le commonwealth et
relations avec les chefs d'état elle est
arrivée
à 25 ans c'était là elle a creusé une
comme ça une place énorme dans ce monde
britannique à la fois du royaume uni
mais aussi à l'étranger à travers des
liens personnels avec nelson mandela
avec des chefs d'état éminent elle a
tissé des liens sur la durée donc il ya
une grande inconnue sur la capacité
justement de ses successeurs à pouvoir
nous et ces relations et à les maintenir
on voit bien les mouvements du côté
notamment d'australie donc on va voir
comment ça va évoluer dans les semaines
qui viennent oui et puis l'enjeu pour
charles iii le nouveau roi donc c'est
d'être le phare que c'est à sa mère a
été pendant 70 ans vous le rappeliez
tout à l'heure de la seconde guerre
mondiale à la guerre en ukraine en
passant par la chute de l'urss le
breakbeat plus récemment elle incarnait
vraiment une continuité dans la tempête
alors certes la monarchie ce conte
continue quel que soit le roi ou la
reine sur le trône mais il ya quand même
quelque chose de l'ordre voilà de la
cassure quoi qu'il faut alors à
l'incarner une stabilité c'est sûr après
il y avait quand même des points
négatifs dans le bilan de son règne est
là la monarchie n'a pas nécessairement
été capable de suivre les évolutions de
la société britannique eux elle n'a pas
eu le soutien des minorités justement
donc ça c'est une grande question sur
les nouvelles générations moins
d'intérêt pour la monarchie - de manière
de pouvoir s'identifier à cette
monarchie alors la sphère a été un peu
différente au moment de l'arrivée de
meghan markle il ya eu une sorte de
rattrapage de cette question des
minorités le prince charles a beaucoup
milité à l'époque aussi pour qu'ils
aient des gars de noirs dans la dans la
garde républicaine c'était dans la gare
de la reine aussi pardon c'était très
important et peu tout ça et de toute
cette évolution n'avait pas été faite la
question justement de la représentation
des minorités est en réalité le départ
du prince harry et de megan aux états
unis a en quelque sorte ruiner ces
efforts là d'ouverture donc c'est vrai
que ça a été un des positionnements du
roi charles iii en tant que prince
régent ça a été de me montrer justement
une ouverture à d'autres fois aussi à
d'autres cultures il a cet atout là dans
sa manche il va falloir qu'il soit
capable d'en jouer il a beaucoup de
payer son divorce
avec diana mais cela aussi peut
permettre d'incarner une sorte
d'évolution de la société britannique
alors est-ce que ça va uniquement le
faire tomber de son statut de roi avec
toute la mystique royal que l'on connaît
comme sa mère qui était une sorte de
reine exemplaires ou est-ce qu'au
contraire plus de britanniques vont
s'identifier à ce roi qui a une vie
finalement plus en adéquation avec
celles de la société d'aujourd'hui c'est
une autre question google a commis
quelques faux pas ces derniers jours
qu'ils pouvaient laisser penser que lui
peut-être pas plus que sa mère mais en
tout cas le cacher - peut-être un peu en
dehors du quotidien classique du
britannique lambda son histoire avec
l'intrigué on a appris qu'il avait je ne
sais combien de vale pour lui mettre son
dentifrice sur sa brosse à dents
peut-être la reine vivaient la même
façon en tout cas on le savait - mais
est-ce que ça va jouer pour lui le fait
d'avoir fait des bains de foule d'avoir
été touchés d'avoir rompu cette barrière
comme ça même du corps du roi avec son
peuple est ce que ça va justement jouer
d'une certaine forme de proximité est ce
que ça va être appréciés ou est-ce que
ça va tuer comme le disent les
monarchistes la mystique royal qui est
finalement d'être de se tenir toujours
au loin avec un air un peu mystérieux de
ne jamais vraiment ni pleurer ni sourire
et de rester à distance du commun des
mortels c'est vrai que cette monarchie
autrefois de droit divin on a remplacé
cette théorie de droit divin par une
famille exemplaire donc c'est le devoir
c'était georges 5 le grand père de la
reine puis georges 6 une monarchie de
devoir une monarchie familiale est
exemplaire donc la reine a représenté
cette monarchie la ses enfants pas du
tout trois divorces sur quatre il ya une
sorte d'éclatement des conflits qui ont
éclaté la reine diana la médiatisation
qui a eu de toutes les disputes elle il
ne peut pas représenter sa donc est ce
qu'il va pouvoir justement trouvé une
nouvelle manière d'incarner une
monarchie moderne ou est-ce qu'au
contraire petit à petit ça va être une
sorte de déclin on peut pas le savoir
mais l'histoire doit être encore écrite
merci infiniment un mot peut-être sur un
tout autre sujet miles besri dudu du
livre que vous avez signé qui s'appelle
les amours dispersé je crois qu elle
nous ramène plus ou moins dans cette
région vous pouvez nous en dire un mot
peut-être oui oui ça se passe pour le
coup entre la france et l'irlande c'est
l'histoire du poète william butler yeats
on dit eva repos est bien sûr irlandais
mais plus grands poètes de langue
anglaise du temps
qui est mort en france et dont le corps
aurait disparu c'est une enquête sur les
traces de ce grand poète disparu où il
est question d'amour aussi merci
beaucoup merci infiniment c'est d'être
venu nous parler de la reine et des
enjeux donc pour cette nouveau règne qui
commence pour charles iii enfin qui a
déjà commencé mais qui prendra sans
doute son essor dans les jours à venir
merci encore bonne journée à vous bon
marathon médiatique nom se retrouve
juste après la pause avec damien coq et
pour la suite de paray direct tout de
suite
[Musique]